almost four months have passed since al
jazeera journalist shaleen abaaklee was
murdered by an israeli soldier in the
occupied west bank despite repeated
calls from human rights organizations
and press freedom advocates for an
independent investigation into the
killing of shireen israel has
consistently refused even ignoring a
call from u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken for such a probe
[Applause]
now israel has released the findings of
what it calls an operational
investigation
they accused investigating themselves
the israeli probe found that quote there
was a high possibility that abu aakley
was accidentally hit by israeli gunfire
that was fired towards what it claimed
was suspects identified as armed
palestinian gunmen
however there has been no evidence to
support israel's claim
chilean was killed in broad daylight
whilst wearing clearly marked press
protective gear
eyewitness statements and video evidence
shows that there was no exchange of fire
and that the veteran journalists
followed all protocol
investigations by al jazeera the new
york times and cnn all established that
sharing was killed by israeli fire in
what many say appear to have been a
deliberate hit
in the immediate aftermath of the
killing israeli officials changed their
narrative seven times in 24 hours
and now four months later whilst
admitting that one of their soldiers was
probably behind the killing
they insist it was a mistake
israeli officials will hope that
releasing these findings will help stave
off criticism but many will question
whether or not it will be enough in the
court of public opinion
shireen abu akla's life matters
for its part al jazeera has vowed to
continue seeking justice for its
murdered journalist
as has shirin's family her brother anton
and niece lena have met with members of
the u.s congress and senate hoping for
washington's help in seeking justice
from its ally
al jazeera is also part of a wider
coalition of media freedom organizations
petitioning the international criminal
court to look into the case of the slain
veteran journalist with other legal
avenues also being explored
since the year 2000 israel has killed
almost 50 journalists and injured
countless more the occupying power has
bombed entire buildings housing media
outlets and recently raided the offices
of internationally recognized human
rights organizations and prevented them
from doing their work many fear that
unless justice is secured for sharing
and everyone involved in her killing is
held accountable then israeli soldiers
will continue to act with impunity
killing whoever they wish
al jazeera
well let's not get the reaction of akiva
eldar who's a columnist with the israeli
daily harass he's joining us from tel
aviv thank you very much for being with
us on al jazeera as we heard there in
jamal's report there was already
overwhelming evidence and several
investigations that found israel
responsible for the death of our
colleague sharina abu akley what do you
make of their findings is there anything
at all in there that stands out for you
well as um the other guest said before
there will be
a
complete
impunity again in this case as uh was
stated in the idf spokesman
statement uh
it's an accident
or as the israeli ambassador to the u.s
said
responding to the letter of
the american
lawmakers who insisted in investigation
he said that they ignored the background
that israel is fighting a deadly wave of
terror attacks so
shireen was
unfortunately
at the wrong time in the wrong place and
this is a kind of
i'm
very embarrassed to say so but most
israelis will see this as collateral
damage she was uh
in a part of a war zone
israel is the victim
and uh
you know journalists happen to be there
and
they're doing their jobs and they have
to take into account
the risks that they've been killed
or the foreign ministry
even accused the media of uh exercising
double standards
as was stated
by one representative of the foreign
ministry
and noah tishby the actor
thousands of journalists were killed in
the recent
years
across the globe from ukraine to
philippines
and only when it comes to israel
is it becomes such a big issue and but
as you say there are thousands of
journalists and palestinians uh in
palestine have been attacked by israel
the case of sharina broadly attracted a
lot of international attention because
as our previous guest said she was a
palestinian-american she was an al
jazeera journalist a well-known
journalist around the world
you know if israel can get away with
this
surely they'll be getting away with much
more when when does it stop when does it
end
um
well in the best case if i want to be
optimistic
in november
lapid will still be prime minister
in the worst case we are going to have
uh
a guy
a clear racist like itamar bandra a
member of the cabinet and netanyahu
back to power
uh and unfortunately
this is the choice of the
israeli voters and uh netanyahu was
there for 12 years and
there are good chances according to the
polls that in the elections in november
he will be back in town
so the question is whether israel will
have to pay and we are talking about
impunity israel has been enjoying the
impunity for 55 years so if the
international community and first and
foremost the united states
uh will accept uh the israeli
explanation that it's you know it's an
accident uh we are very sorry and
actually if you read carefully the
israeli statement they still don't rule
out the possibility that she was shot by
by a palestinian
so
i i wish that i could say that shireen
abracla will be the last victim
of the conflict and the and the
occupation
but uh
i will just add
one figure to the discussion
only the chances that an israeli soldier
will be put out on trial
for killing the palestinian is two
percent
um and uh the message to the israeli
soldier
is that
you have the palestinians are the enemy
and you don't take chances your life
come first and if you believe that
you're putting your life at risk you
kill you shoot
akiva eldar thank you for uh talking to
us and uh giving us a few there from tel
aviv akiva elder columnist with the
israeli daily parets